process of having his head caved in was  really really cool i got to go to this  studio and kind of get this cast made of  my head and then tara my makeup artist  we started maybe five hours and then it  became four hours and maybe three and a  half hours in the makeup chair just  lining the prosthetic up which was my  face which would like squish my eye  and then i had a contact put in and then  the coolest thing about the prosthetic  was the nurse could actually put  stitches through it so they put like  real stitches in my head and i think by  the end of it we've done it so much i  started to get phantom pain like i'd see  myself in the mirror and think that  maybe my head was actually hurting